Amazing.
So, it all started when I was three
years old and my dad came to me and No,
kidding. Everybody quiet. Amazing.
I said everybody. Yes. Thank you. So,
first of all, welcome all to Okay.
Should I? Yes. To the
Let me start over. WELCOME ALL TO THE
FIRST UNPROMPTED.
and didn't you have breakfast this
morning and all the other [\h__\h] Okay,
welcome. Really happy to have you.
Honestly, um excited. I don't often get
that excited being into startups now in
my life. My bar for excitement is kind
of high.
And I truly feel I don't know if you saw
my email this morning, but I started by
saying I'm going to do a very short
manifesto. I'll tell you my significant
other and my right hand at the startup
are forbidding me forever doing
manifestos until I'm one day a
billionaire. Hope not. But I'll still
spend a couple of seconds on things that
matter to me. So, first of all, really
welcome and to everybody online, happy
to have you as well. The Slack link,
this the Slack link
has now stopped working two times over
the last 10 minutes. So, if you don't
have the Slack link, we'll figure it out
in a little bit and maybe send out
another email or show it on on the
screen a little bit later as well.
Number two, for those of you who do not
have the Zoom link or asking friends who
are on the Zoom about the Zoom link,
we'll get you the Zoom link and you can
ask on the Slack. See the problem there
in the support channel and we'll get it
to you immediately. With that said,
appreciate you coming all this way.
Let's get started. So, we had almost 500
submitted talks. We planned for 70 to
120. And I'll tell you, no matter how
many people we had on the review board,
40% of that coming over the last two,
three days was rough. Note for everybody
in the future, please, no matter what
committee you're submitting to, submit
early. Higher chances of getting in.
Even though we covered it, it was quite
a trek. We are now far more than 700.
We're about uh 800 850 attendees on the
online con that we started when we
couldn't take more people because I
reminded you remind you this started at
120 to 200 people con and we had to keep
growing. Salesforce was amazing working
with us throughout, but we had to move
venues just to let people in because it
felt like this community thing. People
need to be here. We can't just tell them
no. And we are out quite a little bit of
money from our pockets, but that's also
okay. There are sponsors. We'll talk
about that in a minute. And then I
really want to thank the committee. It
was really hard reviewing all those
talks. The staff, there's a who most of
you have talked to who can't be here.
She and two other speakers are stuck in
Israel right now. Airspace being closed.
So, thank them as well.
I'm supposed to give some smart
thoughts. I don't have any. So, I I said
I'll probably just share the philosophy
we all already know in four quick points
instead of a large keynote because I am
not the keynote and we don't have one.
Number one, as Sunilu, my co-founder,
likes to say, we are moving from
deterministic to nondeterministic
configuration. I really like that
thought. It helps me focus my mind
around this and trying to understand
what does security look like. Thought
number two for the entrepreneurs. It
feels like this is an anti-artup era.
Every single thing I learned about
startups focus and so on and so forth is
just broken. How do we make it work
anyway in the new world in three months
you don't find product market fit? Pave
it. So hard to do. Third thought is our
teams. I talked to a lot of CISOs, a lot
of CEOs. I'm a CEO right now. I don't
know anything about technology anymore,
right? I'm in the on the business side
and everybody just feels outmoded all
the time. How I'm pretty sure a lot of
the speakers will speak about this too.
How do we keep up? Don't matter if
you're a PhD deep into the math or just
somebody in security or technical person
or in finance. How do you keep up? I
will tell you, we're not outmoded. All
it really takes is trying. I truly
believe that. So those in the audience
who are not deep into this, all it takes
is trying. It feels like the
state-of-the-art is here.
technology will keep going up all the
way somewhere we can't even imagine but
most of us are down here using Chad GPT
or claude like we used to Google we can
learn about how to use multitor have a
conversation move over to agents
download them at this stage talk to them
there will be actions performed there
will be the eugenic [clears throat] loop
the self-healing just knowing how to use
these agents and playing with it already
puts you not here at the current state
of the art but here and if we talk about
cyber power at the level of nations. I
think if instead of investing in so many
uh foundation labs and models, we just
tried to teach people how to use these
tools, right? We would be everywhere
right now. So just try. You're not
outmoded. You're smart people, your risk
executives, your researchers. You can do
it. That's my message for you. Although
I think most people in the room are
already there. And lastly,
actually just said that see what happens
when it's the opening slide. I got
confused. So yes, we are not outmoded.
We are we just need to know English and
we need to try and I'll say that me as
CEO it's not about my R&D team it's
about my finance team it's about HR
everybody needs to use this immediately
cloud code cursor whatever it is you're
using don't wait because I can already
see if the CEO is not spending time on
cloud code regardless of any code I
don't believe that company will survive
personal belief system now this is a
presentation given by Joe Stewart to
another [clears throat] conference I
organized many a year ago called ACOD
which is still running where he said
researcher conferences suck and or he
sucks at networking and I stole his
slides and I'm going to go through this
very quickly. Why do I suck at
networking? He's introverted.
He's bad at small talk and he doesn't
like beer and this is what security
conferences look like. So there are too
many people to have one-on-one
discussions, right? He's bad at that.
Tell you I'm not amazing at it either.
I'm going to read from his slides. Name
tags are too hard to read without being
awkward. Oh yeah, right. Putting faces
to names even if you know the that you
see the picture is really hard. Social
time is usually a noisy bar. How are we
supposed to network? So he wants to
network with people doing similar work.
He wants to find what tools people use.
He wants to establish the informal
sharing relationships. He wants free
stuff. He wants to take care of bad
guys. He wants to be able to for people
to not change free systems to become
paid later on because he's hurting bad
guys right now with these systems and he
wants to not get salespeople to come at
him because of these relationships.
So
he's only lucky enough to come away with
a few people that he might have met to
share with and help. And he wanted a
Tinder app or a Facebook app just to
make meet people, see who they are, how
to work with them. And we ended up
essentially creating something simple
which is our slides where we see a
picture. Who are you? You have your
LinkedIn, what you can offer, what you
can help with. And he's he went first.
This is his from quite a few years ago.
This is mine. So go on the slide deck.
You can't edit it anymore, but you can
email us. If you look at the first
slide, there is an contact at
unprompted.org.
Eda will put it in for you. Main goal,
talk to people.
Thank you for listening to Joe's and my
little rant. That was the first part of
what I wanted to say. Second is just the
stack. I said, "Oh, Slack." See, this is
what happens when you update your slides
last minute. Community feel, right?
Okay. Feel your card. It really matters
because I do believe um warning, I'm
going into manifesto mode again, that
this is a special moment in time. We
live in the future and something special
is going on in this conference.
Honestly, it might not exist next year.
There might be hundreds of conferences.
We might not do any more conferences,
but right now, right this moment, truly
something special is happening here. And
I want us to use it to the max. So
find other like-minded people. Next,
we're going to actually talk in the
Slack. Most conferences don't want you
to be on the Slack, so you don't go to
your phone. You're doing it often enough
instead of looking to the presenters. We
are owning Gen Z. Go to your phone, get
on the Slack, talk to people in the
Slack. will open up a thread for every
single talk. At the end, and most
presenters agreed, we'll share the slide
deck in that thread.
Then
submit an unconference tour talk. There
is an easel in the back. We're going to
have a couple of slots and we are all
going to vote using small sticky notes
with smileys and stars on them. So,
write your proposal on the easel. Put
sticky notes next to what you want to
hear and we'll give time tomorrow to
people. Um, now this is really
important.
other human beings. I prefer dogs.
Some people don't like dogs and you're
horrible human beings and should go. But
the point is I'm forcing you. So, I'm
going to [clears throat] do an HR
moment. We all hate HR moments, right?
We despise HR moments. Look to the right
of you.
Now, look to the left. You can actually
do it with me. Okay? See a person. Say
hi. Just say hi out loud with me. You
don't need to look at them in the eyes.
Hi, everybody. Hi. Okay. Now, you
actually know one more person. Stop
talking. I just said said hi. Don't be
don't be social. But now you actually
know one more person and it will be
easier for you to mingle, join groups,
whatever it is. Try to talk to people.
Try to say hi on the Zoom. Try to just
randomly message somebody and say hi.
There's a lot of there's a full online
conference going on on the Zoom as well.
And timewise, we are already late and we
are planning to be late on time. So
please forgive us for bugs, forgive us
on the schedule, but we're going to try.
So speakers get up there. You have 20
minutes on the mark.
Ah, and then at 20 minutes there are
questions. The next speaker is going to
come up. Start present putting their
laptops in. It will be disruptive to the
questions. It'll work out. And then
attendees questions. You have 30
seconds. Go into this the Slack and say
I want to workshop my question. And
workshop your question. Then you come
up, you ask a question. And if we didn't
have time to get to you, the speaker
will go on the thread and answer your
questions live.
And this is from Galani Cobb. I'm going
to read it. A question is an
interrogative sentence generally denoted
to an inflection at the end. End. I
don't know. Um, a question differs from
a statement in that a question requests
information and a statement provides it.
We prefer questions to statements. And
if you frame your question as succinctly
as possible within 30 seconds, we can
get to as many as possible. Anybody
makes a statements or contributes to the
talks, I'll find you.
Workshop your questions on Slack. Links.
The Slack link obviously no longer
works, but the agenda is online on the
site. You can easily go there. Baseball
cards. Look for people. Ed your own.
Email us with your slides. It will be
fun. Then now lastly before we get
started, Don Hubard who also did this at
one of my older conferences many years
ago was called ISI offered to write a
poem for us to get us started. And you
know what? I think most people in this
room are probably on the spectrum. If
there are normies here, I'm really
sorry. But we're all going to enjoy this
poem. That's an instruction from the
chair. Thank you so much.